does stop your hobbit jokes and get
ready for a new fantasy series to binge
because the Lord of the Rings TV show is
coming and here's everything we know
about it right now on the ketchup
the original Lord of the Rings movie
trilogy each of them certified fresh'
made a combined 2.9 billion dollars at
the global box office so it's no
surprise that amazon paid 250 million
just to get the show and if you factor
in the five season commitment that goes
with the deal you're looking at this
costing more than a billion dollars but
I mean what is that $1 to Jeff Bezos
- We must get it back.
- So, so far we actually don't know much about the cast Variety
reported in July that Australian actress
Mark Kelly Cavanaugh was in talks to
play a character named Tyra
and most recently Variety said that will
Poulter has been cast you know that kid
from that you guys are getting paid
means you guys are getting paid but
there's been no confirmation on who
Poulter might play yet but fans on
social media definitely have an idea and
apparently it's all in the eyebrows I
mean tell me that's not a young Elrond
while the trilogy's oscar-winning
director Peter Jackson has confirmed
that he won't be involved the list of
folks that are working behind the scenes
are basically the Avengers of TV making
showrunners JD Payne and Patrick McCain
we're also slated for upcoming Star Trek
and Flash Gordon films will be joined by
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom director
JAV Jonah who will direct the first two
episodes and as we saw in this video
released on the show social media pages
the writers and producers on the team
have credits that include small shows
you may have heard of before like Game
of Thrones Breaking Bad Sopranos and
stranger things just to name a few
come oh you were born to be as far as
when the series will take place a tweet
from the show with a map of middle-earth
confirmed that it will be during the
second aid so this is before the events
of the Fellowship of the Ring and before
the Hobbit at a time in which the rings
of power including Sauron Zwan ring came
to be good news for fans of the film's
is that the second age setting allows
room for some familiar faces to return
like the previously mentioned Elrond
along with Galadriel and Sullivan played
by Kate Blanchet and Martin so kiss in
the films and Gandalf himself Ian
McKellen didn't rule out the possibility
of reprising his role while on the
Graham Norton Show and let's not forget
that at this point in the Lord of the
Rings history Sauron has the ability to
take human-like form so the great I
could be played by a great actor instead
also can we talk about the fact that
we're going to see so much more Middle
Earth now so production for the series
is set to begin in 2020 with maybe
hopefully something on our screens by
but given the production scale this will
most likely have I'd be shocked if we
see it before Black Panther 2 and I
guess you could say some fans on social
media are pretty pumped for this but I
want to kick it over to you guys now
though are you excited for a Lord of the
Rings TV show will this be the next game
of Thrones for fantasy fans and how
stoked are you to see so much more of
middle-earth now let us know all your
thoughts and feelings in the comment
section and if you liked this episode
and you want to see more subscribe and
click that Bell icon as always thanks
for watching to catch up I'm as Prez and
I'll see you guys next time